hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Arianna
ba Suri
we're gonna check out a video today
called nerds rap fast and comped I don't
know if this is a real video nerds
rapping fast in Compton but whatever
hope so
I'll be cool that'd be cool I would love
it being perky oh shut up phone I decide
to like futuristic performance one song
off his own rooms now excuse me excuse
me guys
would you would you mind if I rap to you
guys yeah I just wrote a song this
morning Anna is my first song I just
want to know if you guys like it and you
just tell me if it's good or not just
cuz yeah like I'm the most underrated
everybody said he's been fighting like a
dragon [ __ ] watch me comin slam coming
from the basement
double XM and I want the cover there's
no way dude I'm not in the conversation
I don't have no patience unless the
space we play an operation I'm
castrating anybody to say ain't trying
to be famous I'm trying to make payment
from what I'm making I'm frustrated
about to go super saiyan and I'm causing
mayhem when I rap I got a coffin in the
back and if you're talking in the
coffins where you at I'm sick I'm
talking on the track I'm exhausted from
your ass and trying to kick it with the
prophets on the Mac [ __ ] make her squirt
like the oldest in a dolphin on his back
but I gotta be cautious in the trap and
up in the Boston and awesome in the
content in the back we're set I'm
sounding like auction when I snap snap
back in the backpack
Jean vets with a fat fast WTF gang
hashtag I guess I'll smoke [ __ ] past
that taking shots duck [ __ ] and black
cash stacks no cat text ever paying to
smash that you differ as fat that I
figure like a car cuz I'll be all in it
might take her on a trip but before I
drop it off I got a wax that Finders
Keepers I'm holding these speakers that
work at you now they're looking terrific
like he chew tobacco all around his
mouth I don't need a deal gotta whip
entertaining though I'm not asleep in
the South I got a crib in there Layton
is giving ad the way I'll be putting
[ __ ] down I'm stepping like a turtle
just like the Merkel they concerned
about me going to commercial killers
shows without rehearsal if I'm before
you watch commercial they committed to
my lyrics that's a verbal copy and
everything that I do let your paternal
person on I'm like a urinal I'll be
probably like a kernel I thought
everyone out the circle the owner any
good okay oh okay you liked it she liked
it I saw her filming huge it man yeah
I'm actually a rapper we filming this oh
oh oh the nerd freestyles and Compton or
nerd raps in Compton or whatever he's
actually a big youtuber oh come on oh
yeah he's a big youtuber and I'm a
rapper so like I'm guest on yeah no way
Down Goes Frazier
rap game Tonio knew it oh that was cool
man
I was [ __ ] rapper I know but do you
know how many rappers are not that fast
no I mean okay I was just caught up on
the whole fact that he's not a nerd okay
yeah oh yes look at the nerd
yeah like parodies laughter okay so you
wanted there to be like a real nerd who
happen to be rapping okay I could tell
he wasn't a nerd
oh yeah he's putting on an act but still
like it's incredibly impressive he was
fast
he's wall shirt - yes that was more hits
than anything well when you first see
him he's dressed like a nerd out of an
eye just like a nerd
yeah but a nerd from the 90s is 2015 hip
tell me I'm wrong
well played well played well played that
rap though was still that made it worth
it like sure I didn't catch everything
he said but he was rhyming the whole
time he was funny brought his own boom
bot yeah starts off like this is around
for young oh [ __ ] man I was so cool let
me get that rap down I'm sorry up a
channel and a couple rings spell
reel-to-reel rejects yapeth I'm gonna be
see that yeah Joe I know median I know
there's oh never make jokes about that
topic on this channel but I'm gonna keep
that one in this video that was good
that was good well everyone knows what
you said but yeah start up a channel I'm
gonna be doing like it's gonna be like
over piano music actually our guitars
and yeah I read a lot of poetry that's
now becoming rap so I know it sounds
silly cuz it's me but check it out
rap music coming at you hey guys if
you're new to the channel you know what
you can do you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out
Ariana's channel where she has fun stuff
on there and we're doing this because
we're trying to be fun youtubers oh look
up look how charismatic we are look up
flooded wacky well there's your key so
quirky oh my god it's funny that they're
willing to be that camera like the hole
in their wall you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
trying to get product placement oh you
know Pena or angel Pena who write it's
been 2 years watching you and I love
your videos man they are cool to watch
and funny your videos make my day and
always make me laugh thanks that's
really sweet
thanks angel Pena he's actually the
guardian angel that looked after Jesus
Christ said that Jesus was going to be
born to the Virgin Mary you know all
this you're Jewish so it was going to be
you know born for the Virgin Mary I just
think it's great that people actually
message you yeah hold on my jokes not
done and I felt though just hold on a
second and Pena
so he's actually the Mexican angel of
the Guardian you know what this jokes
not going anywhere
no what's the joke of this well the joke
I was gonna no no no that wasn't the
punch line I was just a little quick
insert I had in the middle of jokes like
a quick task yeah yeah that's it it was
like a quick little jab but then I was
gonna do the full punchline on angel are
you gonna do it no Pena coming looks
like the word penis doesn't it I thought
you were gonna say that
yeah and his first things on angel if
you take out the G it's actually anal
anal penis that's his real name I did it
I did it I made fun of him